so National Geographic gave us the green
light to produce ingredients way back in
September of 2015 we made 11 episodes
we've been airing them weekly and if
you've been keeping track you know that
that means that last week's episode
about gum sweetener was our last episode
of season 1 and I just wanted to say
thank you whether you just watched or
you watched and commented or tweeted
with episode ideas or ways to make my
versions of the product better or just
jokes about my arm hair which are richly
deserved thank you
now you guys also came up with some
great suggestions for things to do in
future episodes glowsticks seem to be
really popular hair spray deodorant pet
food cigarettes tanning lotion cockroach
killer icy hot instant hot chocolate and
about 85 other things I would love to
make episodes about all that stuff but I
need your help
first subscribe I don't know where the
annotation will be but please subscribe
next maybe pick your favorite episode
and tweet about it or post it on
Facebook or post it to Reddit basically
just help me spread the word about the
show and if you've already been doing
this thank you and the last thing I want
to do is give a huge shout out to
everyone who has helped me make the show
what it is over the past year and a half
Elizabeth Dan pear Bret
Cerie Adam Emily the guys from pick-up
sticks ingredients and everyone from
NatGeo james Danielle will Malena
Lindsay Stephanie Lisa damn Rebecca
Nicola Anna Kelsey gay Becky Todd Teresa
Brett and Leanne alright that's it for
now please subscribe and please share